what the [ __ ] is going on there like
what the fuss are you okay we gotta get
sway real quick yeah
sway hi buddy how are you very that's
right well you like our headphones
that's right
well we're big big show big big show
what's the biggest thing you know that
guy what's his name Howie is smaller
than you guys yeah he has the in ear
buds this [ __ ] well y'all get these what
kind of hundred dollar headphones what
master dynamics yeah master dynamics
yeah um you said that like you really
own - that's right yeah you know I'm
just desperate it's called desperately
desperately showing up everywhere hoping
something sticks you like your own
pimple holing yourself out I really AM
to no avail because you nobody's buying
I'm sucking dick for promises we we have
a very important question yeah because
you know weird your boy Cristian here
yesterday very funny - oh man - [ __ ] out
of here
yeah and we know the money are you
saying I'm you're on your tell Danny's
lurking outside for mini D funny man
he's funny-looking funny clothes do you
know the great Dan Soder Guinness way we
have sway stopping in he uh he cuz
Krista Stefan I was on our show
yesterday yeah I need to know by Dan is
that I wish this microphone was on his
mic is on
No - [ __ ] wait one two three no no no no
Jim Jim Jim this is voice one is Jim I
know sorry Dan Jim running the board
I got sways on well swing came in pop
the merese way the morning's a full five
Monday to Friday 8 a.m. to 12 noon
Eastern sways universe you can see all
the interviews I'm a treeless way if you
love Jim and Sam
follow me too yeah your your YouTube
channel it's very good yeah hey who you
Nina Blackwood or something oh sorry
guys sorry about that player okay here's
our problem we're chris in yesterday and
he popped into your show during the
commercial when he came back he came in
here and told us that he had popped in
and completely bombed on your show he
was not funny what's the problem the
problem is that we didn't realize that
he added something to his expectation
when he came into your studio we notice
that hold on it was maybe maybe
placating to you and your audience a
little bit he Carson Daly a little bit
[Laughter]
yeah I think you know I think we should
hear the moment a professional
broadcaster brings in his friend for a
moment yeah when you were guest on our
show what did you bring us what brought
those laughs player that just made me
quince yeah it's your first time hearing
it oh yeah morning we've been [ __ ]
yeah we've been really bothered by that
friends aren't your [ __ ] car deal
walking over to the black eye on the I
had a view Senator John McCain wants any
any kind of good did that to John
McCain's in Vietnam Chris almost started
a race war within our studio when he did
that
[Laughter]
I'd love to see Chris coming out and
catch a nice beating in Swiss do he got
this show he is talking chance Paula
Terry what happened with McCain I'm
surprised to hear McCain did that
actually I'm a big fan of home of his
because of his military salute League I
know my family is I'm a hip-hop guy do
you think that I'm interviewing
Grandmaster Flash later on unfiltered
and so I'm watching this evolution of
hip-hop it's [ __ ] great
yeah yeah it's really good that's really
good not been mentioned once though I'm
really annoyed I was one of the first
white kids on that bandwagon that's true
I do like though the rap fans have to
tolerate that blondie gets a lot more
credit that she deserves
oh yeah but she they said she brought it
to the mainstream a little bit like
people like we were recognized after her
but you know what did John McCain do
whole I want to discuss blondie alright
he cracked a joke about mm this is when
he was go when he deferred when
President Obama and Senator Obama at
that time and John McCain were both from
the campaign campaign age yeah 2007
really when they wanted a campaign trail
and Halen yeah and a joke was something
about somehow he called me ugly
you know my grandfather used to do that
sort of thing like yeah
if I had a face like yours I would even
ask the question my dog had a face like
yours I'd shave its ass and teach it to
walk backwards when he said I didn't
understand I was just sold in fact I was
serious serious guy yeah before I start
working in Sirius XM like yours that
break both your legs and throw you in
the Hanoi Hilton
[Laughter]
were you insulted when Chris did that to
you guys because you should have been I
was insulted for you know cuz I've seen
Chris do Dumber things we can do we can
do like he put on an accent or what did
he do when he told the joke he kind of
did wonder Mike yes I did never mind the
buzzcocks with wonder Mike exactly but
he was trying to find common ground I
appreciate it he was trying to loosen me
up dude yeah you know I mean the ugly
joke didn't work for me did the wrong
with the wrong way yeah I'll just
shattered my confidence you know I was
about the interviewer senator I was you
know it's real nerve-racking thing my
friend we had a great conversation and I
told her I really appreciated his
service to the country and yeah I like
McCain yeah I like McCain man you know I
got to do is get that Donald Trump
interview how are you gonna do Trump at
all over the years Ivanka but not but
not on Donald Trump I'd almost I would
love to interview her we've talked to
Donald on the phone I would like the
interview Ivanka Turk the Donald Trump
on the phone II called you guys pigs
we called them pigs on me that's true
yeah well then I haven't got that one
yet back on your show someday I would
love to yeah man you did a lot better
than Chris
[Laughter]
prostitute anytime we're right next door
brother okay by the great's way nice job
with Obama by the way he did a good
under that that's not that you know it's
that's scary to interview the sitting
president you're very good thank you man
have you talked to him since yeah he
tenth he texted me the other day
Hawaii I'll get back to him you know you
know you've lost a little power when
you're waiting for him to walk in the
room and you know that you're seated and
ready to the worst what are you what are
you thinking or what's what's happening
as you're saying they're waiting for him
to come in the room the last time I
interviewed him we were live from the
White House on MTV from the Blue Room
and I had to get there three hours in
advance and wait and so for three hours
I was a tortured soul wondering how am I
gonna conduct this interview was twenty
three minutes that's all we had it's a
long time for non life today but I had
about 15 really cool questions I wanted
to get to he averages about two and a
half three minutes an answer I wouldn't
get to all the questions and then when
he finally came into the White House
they they had me sitting waiting where
we were gonna do the interview for maybe
thirty minutes 45 minutes you saw the
Secret Service come in and then he came
in from another room and I just heard
him say yo swear yeah what'd you say at
you know yes wait wait wait you know
he's just yelling coming into the room
and everybody in the room just kind of
went and I just sat there mom man
president barack obama tell you Jim you
know I take that work very seriously you
know here I'm relaxed but you know I
knew it was a very important interview
and it was questions I want to get to
that hadn't been addressed at that time
that to CERN our target demographic and
on the whole time I'm trying to get my
game face right before we go live and I
do this thing where I close my eyes and
I kind of visualize what I'm expected to
do and and usually nobody's sitting
there with me but he was sitting next to
me and I closed my eyes and I'm prepping
my head one minute I heard 30 seconds
left when I look up and he's staring at
me
and then he just started nodding at me
like oh that's your process I see your
process and meanwhile I'm like damn but
I like to do it alone man on the planet
like they said three two one go and this
is like when you run in the track me
once the gun shoots off me all your
nerves and everything leaves and got a
job Marc Maron said that when he came to
do his podcast Maron said the first
thing he does he's walking up the
driveway and goes Marc like he's just
very engaging I think that kind of
relaxes you like he knows who I am this
is not and he knows how to relax people
yes he could have [ __ ] you up right
before when he saw you getting into your
place if he just leaned over he's like
aliens in all my past co-workers thank
you for doing a great ad for these
headphones to hopefully they'll keep
coming in at real sway you guys follow
me if you care follow this way